au début c'était un peu underground
c'était un petit événement c'est devenu
la base chaque dimanche après midi si
vous passez devant le mont royal voyez à
ces fameux tam-tam d'ailleurs l'écart de
nourriture sont là il ya du monde c'est
très beau c'est très bien mais le
lendemain matin cauchemar pour les
employés de la ville de montréal et cols
bleus les poubelles débordent c'est
vraiment on parle entre 100 et 150 sacs
chaque lundi matin émilie dubreuil a
suivi une équipe de nettoyage justement
c'était en 1994 danseurs et
percussionnistes eux réunis chaque
dimanche pour danser autour de la statue
georges étienne cartier étaient encore
en relatif petit comité
quelques centaines de personnes
peut-être
vingt ans plus tard ils sont des
milliers à venir couler leur dimanche
après midi au son des percussions et les
lendemains de la veille sont de plus en
plus dur
le parc a parfois des allures de
dépotoir loyer si l'on réveille environs
du matin
ça fait 20 ans que claude nicol travail
sur le mont royal
c'est lui qui dirige la petite amie
d'une vingtaine de cols bleus chargés du
grand ménage
si on gagne en termes de sacs ce qu'on
fait connu comme un lundi matin où c'est
vraiment à cause des tam-tams la veille
où c'est vraiment la grande journée l'on
peut ramasser facilement 555 ya la
clusaz en plus mais l'élément qui vient
justement rajoutez à ça c'est la
délinquance c'est le vandalisme aussi
mais ça ça se passe la nuit parce que si
ses joueuses de ramasser la consommation
courante
nous les gens sont disciplinés il ya
aussi une autre classe qui moins visible
c'est que ce qui est re sic par exemple
les bouteilles cette équipe est des
poubelles et ramasse les bouteilles
mises en avant mais il n'ya pas que les
secteurs des tam-tams à nettoyer le
lundi matin
la superficie du mont royal seyssel
celle des îles donc c'est 200 hectares
donc c'est évident qu'on peut pas aller
partout tout à la fois et s'est occupée
partout on voit un exemple ici il ya des
gens qui viennent deux fois pour passer
la nuit
des colis km 6 a cédé des rixes et dans
ma chute à des beuveries pour la paix
afin que vous avez à ramasser la paix
obama
il y reste deux techniques font des
heureux
il ya des ratons il ya des écureuils il
ya des renards aussi il ya quand même
quelques renards sur la montagne et auto
sens bien nourrie oui sont bien nourris
surtout là les fans cela nous est il des
gros rat temps on vienne encore à rome
jean même plupart de nous lire at ans a
ému les laver la tête trouver la
solution à ces poubelles qui débordent
pas une solution toute simple papier
vous voyez derrière moi là c'est la
poubelle standards qu'on trouve sur le
mont royal elle contient entre 180 et
200 litres
alors la solution c'est de grossir les
poubelles et la ville songe à acheter à
acquérir et installer ici des poubelles
qui sont semi souterraine qui pourrait
contenir jusqu'à 5000 litres de déchets
c'est donc 25 fois la capacité de cette
poubelle ici sur le parc du mont royal
où se déroulent les tam-tams et où on
trouve les dommages le lundi matin le
sait encore à l'étape de projet mais la
ville a déjà fait l'acquisition de 14 de
ces poubelles qu'elle va installer dans
les prochaines semaines dans des
endroits névralgiques
à montréal on passe au quartier des
spectacles à la place émilie gamelin et
à la place jacques-cartier
c'est très bien merci un millier
attention jours s'est grossi belle a
taclé jours pour mieux vous voir tu veux
dire est que pas mal d'écureuil assez
joufflu oui salut merci d'aller